bonsoir yannick effet merci d'être avec
nous on vient de le voir sur ces images
le nombre d'agressions sur votre
profession à les sapeurs pompiers n'a
fait qu'augmenter ces dernières années
quel est votre état d'esprit ce soir
deux jours après cette nouvelle attaque
envers les soldats du feu rectangle
bonsoir merci merci de m'inviter dans
votre émission
écoutez notre état d'esprit les
désespérés parce que nous venons de
franchir encore un cap ce n'était pas la
première fois que les sapeurs pompiers
se faisait tirer dessus mais c'était
parfois sur leurs véhicules ou à côté
hélas un sapeur pompier a été touché par
une arme à feu ont franchi un cap
je suis désolé de dire que les discours
des politiques
nous en avons assez ils nous doivent la
protection du style jean 40 ans d'une
armada nous la terre tout à l'heure mais
dans les faits il n'y a pas de
protection parce qu'il n'y a pas de
services de police pour pouvoir le faire
donc c'est vraiment plus que désespérant
et les sapeurs-pompiers sont à bout et
réfléchissent la dissolution en quasi il
légal pour pour se mettre à l'abri
comment vous vous expliquer cette
augmentation des agressions dit autant
que les populaires les pompiers sont
parmi les professions les plus
populaires en france on a du mal à se
l'expliquer le métier de sapeur pompier
est le plus populaire de france parce
que l'immense majorité des français ça
parce que ce qu'ils doivent aux sapeurs
pompiers et à tous les services
départementaux d'incendié et de secours
en revanche là on a affaire à des
délinquants à des criminels puisque
mettre le feu à des poubelles le mettre
le feu à des local poubelles à des
voitures c'est un délit tirer sur sa
part conclu moyen d'une arme à feu s'est
pas créé et en fait ce sont des gens qui
sont exclues complètement de la société
française de par leur comportement mais
qui n'est pas propre à ce qu'il puisse
faire aux sapeurs pompiers ils ont le
même comportement avec des gens qui y
pénètre dans leur territoire
que ce soit le facteur se soit glisse
vers d'amazon que ce soit le médecin que
ce soit n'importe qui en fait quelqu'un
qui est étranger à leur territoire et
c'est une d'un prétexte pour pour
agresser pour s'amuser puisque pour moi
je vois même pas ça comme une défense
des territoires puissent commune et la
luz mans vous représentez l'état pour
eux ou c'est même plus bête que ça ces
gens se dire à travers à travers vous
c'est l'état qu'on attaque d'une
certaine manière
certains veulent va la voir cette excuse
et je peux je peux prêter cette excuse
entre guillemets à certains kinés qui
n'est pas pour autant quelque chose
d'acceptable mais pour moi effectivement
c'est plus quelque chose de bêtes c'est
c'est vraiment on sait pas quoi faire
maintien on a eu un feu de poubelle et
puis bon premier client de callas ainsi
c'est la police basque accueille 6 et
les pompiers si les pompiers et puis bah
parfois plutôt que cas et c'est tiens on
va voir jean du juge et j'ai touché mon
pain de long rifle changer dcb est un
sapeur pompier touché au mollet comment
clairement interviennent ces agressions
lorsqu'on vous êtes en intervention vous
venez d'en parler un petit peu
voilà on ti on envoie des caillasses et
c'est comme ça que ça se passe
clairement oui alors hier vous avez le
prétexte du 14 juillet comme comme
d'autres événements nationaux tels que
31 décembre la nuit de la saint
sylvestre
on a souvent affaire à des gens qui
veulent un record de cette poubelle
cette voiture ou de feux d'artifice et
donc quand on voit les mortiers sur les
pompiers que sur les policiers là le 14
juillet c'est un autre prétexte commun
comme un autre effectivement dans ce
genre de l'événement festif c'est comme
ça que ça se passe où ou créer plusieurs
petits feux alors on joue au chat et à
la souris avec la police des pompiers et
il n'y a pas d' agression c'est un jeu
quand même dû collectionner du nombre de
feux dans dans le dans le quartier où
alors ou alors maintien on va se faire
on va se faire un pompier policier ce
coup ci les attendront puis on va s'y
mettre à plusieurs pour le calaisis
c'est exactement comme ça que ça se
passe
un guet-apens dénis les sapeurs pompiers
ni la police n'ont de
comportement qui vise à provoquer la
population locale
kyoshin c'est clairement ce sont
clairement des catalans est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui clairement pardonnez moi
comment répondre à ces à ces agressions
qui augmente quelles sont vos
revendications quelle est la solution
la solution ce n'est pas que
sapeur-pompier qui l'a mieux nous sommes
des victimes
c'est à la société civile de trouver
cette solution voix lorsque j'entends le
de nos ministres
lorsque j'entends les préfets tout le
monde s'est mobilisé la presse à chaque
fois qu'un événement de ce genre comme
vous le faites aujourd'hui on vous en
remercie d'attirer l'attention du public
sur sur ces phénomènes mais à chaque
fois entré on demande à ce que les
sapeurs pompiers puissent avoir une
intervention sécurisée par les forces de
sécurité publique ce n'est pas aux
pompiers de faire sa propre sécurité
le pompier il a déjà sa sécurité a pensé
dans le cadre d'un feu de désir
attention que je me blesse pas que je
sauve les gens que d'autres personnes ne
soient pas blessés
s'ils commencent à devoir penser en q ce
qu'il faut ne pas prendre une balle un
coup de couteau ou un caillou on va pas
être bien on demande tout simplement
parce que les services de l'état puisse
assurer notre sécurité en intervention
et pour ça il faut des moyens des moyens
policiers quand j'entendais des
collègues dire pourquoi pas des gilets
pare balles on a autre chose à faire que
de mettre des gilets pare-balles on
l'aimé déjà so that le terroriste parce
que c'est vraiment contexte particulier
mais paramètres des gilets pare balles
pour aller au feu qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire des gens
techniquement c'est pas possible
la police systématiquement oui dans les
cartes le ministre de l'intérieur a
annoncé avoir déposé plainte et a
réaffirmé en soutien indéfectible à
votre profession sapeurs pompiers est ce
que c'est suffisant c'est ce que vous
attendez du nouveau ministre de
l'intérieur une plainte systématique
écoutez ont renversé nice d'intérieur de
d'avoir pris des nouvelles de collègues
qui s'est déplacé au froid des collègues
des temps c'est important de montrer
l'attachement de la république
pourquoi des sapeurs pompiers maintenant
on ne veut pas que des paroles on veut
effectivement que le ministre tienne ses
engagements et tout simplement en
mettant des moyens policiers est allé
demander à la police s'ils sont
suffisants pour aller faire des
patrouilles pour pouvoir sécuriser
chaque intervention de sapeurs-pompiers
la réponse est non systématiquement non
parce qu'il n'y a pas de moyens
financiers et humains
c'est laisser encore on en revient
toujours à la même chose faire des
économies sur le sacrifice du service
public c'est vrai pour des sapeurs
pompiers c'est vrai pour la coller c'est
vrai pour les hôpitaux les abus commis
19 pourrait pour tous tout le sel de ce
public est en train de se casser la
figure et donc à chaque fois qu'un
ministre nous dit on va porter plainte
vous avez notre soutien on va tout faire
pour sécuriser derrière il n'a pas le
moyen humain et il n'y a que celui là il
n'y a pas 150 autres je parle pas de
même des moyens de la justice lorsqu'on
arrive à attraper ces délinquants à ces
criminels
ça c'est une autre histoire mais on
voudrait ne pas en arriver là c'est à
dire qu'on voudrait c'est ce que
personne ne nous allons donc pour ça il
faut des moyens policiers et on ne les a
pas et la seule réponse ces derniers
mois le gouvernement a pu lui donner ce
sont des caméras piétons et là en cas
d'espèce on voit très bien que le
collègue qui s'est fait tirer dessus la
caméra piétons ne sert à rien je ne m'en
porte pas au feu on les porte que sur
les interventions de secours à personne
donc la caméra qu'étant ce n'est pas la
solution
merci yannick tennessee d'avoir été avec
mon président du syndicat national des
sapeurs pompiers professionnels merci à
vous bon courage